[Musique]
ce dimanche 1er décembre avait lieu la
15e journée mondiale de lutte contre le
sida
quinze années de lutte contre le virus
de l'immunodéficience humaine qui tue
encore selon l'institut national de
veille sanitaire l'île de france est une
des régions française la plus touchée en
2001 2,3 cas était décelée pour 1000
habitants
je me rends compte que la maladie qu'on
croyait
envoi de
non pas de disparition bien entendu mais
des diminutions est en train de prendre
un nouvel essor sur les yvelines selon
li nvs entre le 1er avril 2001 et le 31
mars 2002 21 cas de sida ont été
notifiés ce qui porte à 1159 cas cumulés
depuis 1978
le centre de dépistage anonyme et
gratuit implantée à l'institut de
promotion de la santé à trappes depuis
janvier 2002 a déjà accueilli 460
personnes à la fin du mois d'octobre
si la population venant faire le test
est plutôt hétéroclite les médecins
observent une présence accrue des jeunes
les rapports entre eux sont extrêmement
fréquents
il y à peu je dirais de gens qui ont des
relations suivies avec le même quand
même personne la jeunesse
je dirais
qui à 20 ans à l'heure actuelle c'est
essentiellement elle qui a oublié qu'il
fallait faire attention
le profil des populations contaminées
évoluent les personnes hétérosexuelles
sont aujourd'hui davantage touchés
d'autre part certaines communautés sont
particulièrement exposés un des
principal foyer d'infection aujourd'hui
c'est l'afrique subsaharienne
donc il ya une vraie réalité de
l'épidémie dans cette communauté d'à
donc ce que comme si vous disiez tout à
l'heure c'était d'abord de changer
le déni dans cette communauté en fierté
de smoby da en fierté de ce mobile i de
se mobiliser
l'association aide s'est installée ali
ps depuis le mois d'octobre dernier pour
se rapprocher des populations à risque
souvent en situation de précarité
si la baisse de vigilance est
aujourd'hui l'une des causes de la
progression de la maladie en france
l'accès généralisé aux traitements
thérapeutiques y participe largement la
quadrithérapie et la trithérapie on va
le dire dans ce sens là sont des
traitements qui ne soigne pas ne sont
pas curatif pour la maladie mais qui
essentiellement retarde l'apparition de
cette maladie
ces traitements des effets secondaires
lourds les gens n'ont pas forcément
conscience
il est donc important de rappeler que la
prévention est la meilleure des
solutions
[Musique]
avec la fin de la période hivernale la
semaine dernière les restos du coeur ont
distribué leurs derniers paniers repas
jeudi une nouvelle saison de trois mois
bien remplie depuis leur ouverture le 14
décembre dernier avec un net
accroissement du nombre des
bénéficiaires de l'ordre de 25% et une
nouvelle tendance de plus en plus de
personnes seules et à rêver comment
s'est passée sa te faisons bien très
bien dure beaucoup de monde
une équipe de bénévoles extra à peu près
35 bénévoles qui ont tourné tout les
toutes les semaines
alors à à ce jour c'est provisoire en
jeu donne des chiffres provisoires
on doit être là pour la saison à 42
mille repas pour les quatre communes
concernées c'est-à-dire elancourt moore
pas coignard la verrière nous avons en
plus qui sont venus se greffer des gens
de rambouillet et des environs cette
année nous avons rencontré beaucoup de
personnes seules
on avait à peu près 55 à 60 personnes
seules choses que nous n'avions pas les
autres années derniers coups de balai
donc et grand nettoyage de printemps
pour ce local les congélateurs et les
frigos sont débranchés seuls seront
gardés les boîtes de conserve ou les
denrées non périssables changements à
prévoir pour l'année prochaine le
déménagement de ce resto du coeur
implantée à la maison de quartier de la
nouvelle amsterdam depuis sept ans pour
le centre de la maison des droits de
l'homme jacques prévert toujours sur
elancourt près du carrefour des quatre
arbres
[Musique]